what I wanted to talk about was building
an audience on social media and you
talked about Twitter and and sometimes
you feed the trolls and sometimes you
don't so how has it been for you
building an audience on social media and
maybe talk about some of your pet peeves
you see from other performers on social
media I enjoy social media very much I
really love the direct engagement with
an audience at your fingertips any time
of night you know early late sober very
not sober I love that my fingertips I
can just communicate even upload video
I'm a production studio in my pocket neo
so you guys wild set these lights up yet
we could have done it on iphone it would
be some people might like it more am I
like it not as much it's nice to have
production value but the point is it's
amazing that we can communicate in an
instant without any barriers to that
entry anymore however it's frustrating a
little bit that I have fine often times
that the smarter stuff tends to get the
fewest retweets and the fewest favorites
and you have to often times we really
course or just make a joke about sex or
just make something budget about
something very stupid or mean very
overtly mean that blows up but when you
do something more thoughtful or smart it
does not that's frustrating I guess you
know social media can always be
dependent to be the most thoughtful
intelligent folks out there some are of
course they're out there but you know
it's just a little annoying and then
people are little selfish with it too
you know the advent of the favorite like
you people like cently retweet it and
then it would spread it wider and then
people discover the favorites tab and
they're like oh I can just click heat
that in my favorites I like it but I
don't like it and want to share it I'm
fine keeping this to myself I like it
but just not quite enough so you get
like a great joke you're right out there
you'll get like a lot of favorites and
the small amount of retweets and if it
was the flip you'd be able to
exponentially grow your audience bigger
that's just important because it's very
nice to you're putting your you're all
of your energy into something you're
creating it's nice you get it reached to
as broad an audience as possible so they
can enjoy it and you know get from that
entertainment what you're trying to
create with it you know I don't know how
other comics stick with it when they I
have as much smaller number than
obviously people that have been the
hundreds of thousands and millions of
followers but
I don't know comics who are tweeting and
instagramming four years have like 300
followers or a thousand followers god
blessed them I don't know how they keep
and you have to you have to make it
about the work but at some point I
wonder if you feel like you're talking
to just yourself you know and I hope at
least it's climbing for them you know so
i try to retweet comedians that I
respect and enjoy and follow who or
don't have as much following when I can
because I want them to be exposed to
bigger audiences but you know just not
to surpass me it'd be good if they get
just right below my audience size sure
or less anything just anywhere here but
just not they shot past me would be
unpleasant kidding it's not so many
times of course have it many times we've
been plenty people that I helped come up
in their career and gave spots to and
help them get stage time when they were
had no name whatsoever and have shot far
past me as far as Thatcher in the
industry and sometimes they're really
cool and nice and remember that and
sometimes they do not and are really not
so nice about it and it's all good
people can be as they will you just you
know keep it in mind and move on
you